discipline equals Freedom episode 4 Joo
here also have Carrie and Leif in the
house um I was doing a live event I
think it was the one in New York I was
doing a New York Joo live and I'm get to
the Q&A portion and this guy stands up
and asks a
question and and basically his question
is that he's having a hard time finding
discipline staying discipline type
scenario and he kind of goes through his
life he's you know I'm pretty happy I
got a good job I got a good family I got
a nice house I'm in pretty good shape so
he's doing good right and he says but
you know I can't find dis the discipline
you know I sometimes I skip workouts and
sometimes I sleep in and sometimes I eat
bad and sometimes I watch a little too
much TV with and I just how can I find
more discipline is this question and I'm
I'm sitting there thinking about
it and I thought through all these
different possible scenarios that could
be going on and finally I'm like you
could be lying to yourself that could be
the
problem how is that you can be lying to
yourself by
saying I'm really
happy that can be a lie it can be a lie
hey you know what I'm really happy right
now and there's a chance you are right
there's a chance there's a chance that
you're really are truly happy I got a
good job I got a good family I got a
house I'm in pretty good shape there's a
chance that you're truly hap happy in
that situation and if that's the
scenario good you know what don't worry
about getting more discipline you're
you're happy you're content you got a
good job you got a good family you got a
house you got a car everything's good
that's
cool that's
fine but there's a
chance that that's not fine there's a
chance that that you're lying to
yourself and that's why you're asking
this question by the way the reason
you're asking this question is because
you can't find more discipline you want
more discipline why do you want that
because you know you could be better and
there's something in your mind that's
saying you could be better and you know
it and you know that the way you could
get better and the way you could do
better and the way you could be more is
by having more
discipline
so don't lie to yourself
that that's what we have to do we have
we have to not lie to ourselves and this
is why JP uses this quote a lot because
I ended up telling JP like two weeks
later or something we are at a gig
together discipline is rooted in the
truth we tell
ourselves that that's what it is
discipline is rooted in the truth we
tell ourselves because if you tell
yourself the truth if you tell yourself
the truth and the truth is I'm not happy
with where I'm at that's the truth the
truth is I can do more the truth truth
is I can be in better shape the truth is
I can work harder than I'm working right
now the truth is I can do more for my
family the truth is I can do much better
than I'm doing right now and if that's
the real
truth if that's what you believe if you
believe that to be the truth you won't
have to find more discipline discipline
will find you it will wake you up in the
morning it will wake you up in the
morning have you ever been like
preparing for something and you didn't
think you were ready and you couldn't
sleep and you wake up in the morning cuz
it's happening 100 times million times
ever happened to you life definitely hey
when you're many times missions going
out on a mission like let's say you're
you're in Iraq and you're going out on a
mission you haven't been on a mission
before let me ask you this the first
mission you did in Iraq with me when we
were there together how well did you
sleep the night before I don't think I
slept at all why is that trying to think
every every contingency you know so much
work left undone uh just not confident
in in knowing that that all all the the
uh you know all the eyes were dotted and
the te's were crossed and everything was
done and prepared as it should be and
and you're also thinking about scenarios
that might unfold like worst case
scenarios and um and it's it's kind of
just spinning yeah in your head isn't
that interesting you what what makes
that interesting is you've got a
specific scenario that's happening that
you want to be ready for and therefore
it your mind prevents you from sleeping
that's what happens so when you're going
through life and you truly feel like you
could do better and you could do
more and you truly feel that way and you
think about that you you're going to
have a hard time sleeping and look I'm
not encouraging non sleeping every I'm
not doing that but when you if you think
about that and you say oh yeah I could
do better you're going to have a hard
time sleeping you're going to discipline
is going to find you now if you lie to
yourself if you lie to yourself if you
would lie to yourself and say you know
what I I'm good to go like I'm not
worried about this operation we're good
to go I I know everything will probably
go fine I'm good you sleep all night
like a little baby if you lie to
yourself and you're like well you know
I'm I'm in pretty good shape and I got
my family's doing fine and I like this
house that I'm in and my job my job's
good
enough if that's the lie that you're
telling yourself maybe you can sleep
just fine and maybe it's hard to be
disciplined in those scenarios
so what you need to do is you need to
tell yourself the truth about what the
hell is going on in your life that's
what you need to do you need to do an
assessment you need to break out a piece
of paper and start to write down these
things that you claim to be happy about
and pull the pull pull the stops off
like okay what if I if I could have any
house I wanted is this house the house I
wanted is
it is it is it really you sure about
about
that you sure about that you sure about
that you see what I'm saying if you ask
yourself hey I'm in pretty good shape
right now you sure about that you sure
about that and you write down well what
if if I could snap my fingers and be in
a different physical shape is this what
I would choose or would I want to be a
little bit better would I want to be
stronger
faster am I happy where I'm at with my
Jiu-Jitsu I'm pretty good I've been
training for a while I can beat most
people that's pretty good
right then you got ask yourself you sure
about
that are you sure about
that because we end up lying to oursel
and if we're lying to ourselves we're
not going to find the discipline it's
it's going to be more difficult you have
to do an assessment you have to detach
from it you have to write it down and
then you have to ask yourself is is this
the truth right here that I'm saying and
like I said dude if you're happy with
that and you you pull back you peel back
the onion and you look at it you say you
know my house is awesome like it's a
really good house and maybe you have to
weigh some things out and you say you
know my house is pretty good and if I
was to really want a bigger house I'd
have to work so much more that I
wouldn't be able to see my family you
know what I'm good with it that's fine
that's perfectly fine but maybe you're
not getting to spend time with your kids
in the morning because you're sleeping
late and now they're going off to school
and you haven't said good morning to
them haven't sat down and eaten some
some bacon with them or done a quick
workout with them and you know it would
make you better and you know it would
make them better but you're not doing it
why cuz you're being
lazy so tell yourself the truth about
the situation that you're
in that's what we need to
do and it should hurt a little bit by
the
way it should hurt a little bit there
should be aspects of your life that you
know you can improve
upon that should hurt a little
bit here's here's the cool thing take
ownership of those things and guess what
doesn't hurt at all now guess who's in
control you
are but if you're having trouble finding
discipline start by telling yourself the
truth about what's going on I'm going to
go to the book here discipline freedom
field manual where where does discipline
come
from it comes when you make a decision
to be
disciplined really hold on a second this
is a choice is that is that what I just
said is that what I just said right
there it's a choice I mean you mean
you're not born with discipline hey this
is your baby boy he's got brown hair
blue eyes and level seven discipline is
that what happens negative no that's not
what happens you actually as a human
being get to decide if you want to be
disciplined or not back to the book when
you when you make a decision to be
better now if you've already told
yourself that hey I'm pretty good to go
you don't make a decision to be better
cuz you already think you're there there
you lie to yourself and you're not going
to make this decision if you lie to
yourself you're not going to make the
right decisions back to the book when
you make a decision to do more to be
more self-discipline comes when you
decide to make your mark on the
world if you don't think you are
disciplined it's because you haven't
decided to be
disciplined
yet it's because you haven't created it
yet it's because you haven't
become
disciplined
yet because you haven't told yourself
the truth and this is going to be
problematic it's going to be very
problematic so where does discipline
come from it comes from
you become the discipline Embrace its
cold and Relentless
power hell yeah I like that
line and it will make you better and
stronger and smarter and faster and
healthier than anything
else and most
important it will make you
free so that's what we're doing that's
where we're at go this guy sounds
comfortable the guy who was talking to
you absolutely what what effect do you
think Comfort plays on our ability to
tell ourselves the truth
well comfort's kind of a a
a it massages lies right it makes them
feel good it it makes it feel like it's
okay and you know that happens in in
people's lives happens with everybody
right I mean it happens you know what
happens with rock and roll bands right
rock and roll bands when they're young
and they're struggling and they're
hungry and they're they're poor
and their music is reflects that but
it's hard to you know write good music
when there's someone massaging your
freaking throat as you're drink eating
caviar or whatever it's hard to be like
disgruntled about things so their music
tends to get worse and worse as time
goes on it's like Fighters too right
yeah it's it's hard for a
fighter in silk sheets to get up and go
for a run in the cold biting
air you can't live like that you can't
allow yourself to get there you got to
be careful of that because it's a real
thing yeah Comfort breeds
lies and it breeds a lack of discipline
absolutely because because that's where
you're at and that's you know as much as
I talk about look imposed discipline is
not our goal right we don't want imposed
discipline but but you were talking
earlier about before we hit record today
you know one of these one of these other
discipline equals Freedom episodes that
I did I was saying listen you're the
general you're in charge you're also the
soldier what is what do they teach you
about discipline in the Marine Corps uh
so in Marine Corps basic training in
boot camp we have diddies and one of
those dides is about discipline and the
the first call from a drill instructor
is discipline and then all the recruits
say uh discipline and they spell it out
d i s c i p l i n e and then he says
discipline is and the recruits say
discipline is uh immediate willing
obedience to all orders sir and that's
where in my brain I try to attach that
to the orders I'm giving myself right if
you're the general and you're giving
yourself orders immediate willing
obedience to all orders from me yes do
it do the thing that's what I Tred to
tell I'm the general I'm the soldier I
am going to obey orders without question
and you've heard me talking about this
for years right now right the
negotiation the debate the what and
people say like what do you tell
yourself I'm telling myself anything I'm
not allowed to
talk I'm not allowed to talk we're not
allowed to we're not allowed to come up
with these things it's like you know the
Marine Corps recruits not like well
actually I'd like to wonder why why
we're doing this why you want me to go
over there it's not happening not
allowed to do that you're not doing
it immediate obedience to the orders
that's what we're doing with ourselves
and listen do we
encourage this idea of imposed
discipline on other people no you've
heard me discourage it for years I don't
even encourage it with your kids and
listen Beyond Marine Corps boot camp in
the military I don't encourage hey
immediate response immediate obedience
to my orders I don't even want to have
to give you orders matter of fact what I
want is you're doing it before I even
thought of it that's what we really want
that's what we want to get to but the
way we treat ourselves as general and
Soldier what we need is immediate
obedience without question that's what
that's what we're moving towards and
here's the
thing if there's lies if the general
lies to the Troops there's no trust
there's debate there's negotiation if
the soldiers lie to the general there's
no trust there's lies there's debate so
we can't let that
happen we tell the truth up and down the
chain of command in our
heads so that there can be no question
you were asking about you know first
combat operations whether or not I was
sleeping you know good the night before
and I I think what gives
you after that first combat operation
you realize okay I there's a there's a
lot of things are out of my control I
got to focus Fus on what I can control
and you you know you can prioritize and
ask on those things but the the more
disciplined that we were in planning and
preparation like the easier you sleep at
night because you know that you you've
done everything you can um and uh and
and you can go to sleep knowing they're
like we're fully prepared and we're
ready uh and I think that that's a I had
a leader ask me about this recently um
and she was she was talking about like
not being down on herself well you know
we're holding the standard really high
and we have to be disciplined and you
know kind of similar to the question
that you got that that that you you
reference of this person that's that's
they know they could do be better but
you know it's but they don't want to
like be they they they're driving their
confidence into the ground because
they're constantly like you know holding
the standard too high and and so the the
question was like how do you gain more
confidence and the only way to gain that
confidence is through discipline and and
that discipline preparation is what gets
you confidence it doesn't matter whether
you're playing a sport whether you're in
school studying for a test whether
you're not preparing for a presentation
you know at work um or whatever it is
that you're doing planning for a combat
Mission I mean the more disciplined you
are in that preparation the the more
confidence you're going to have and I
think for for me I notice if I get off
the path it's it
becomes it's easier to lie to yourself
you know and so that slipp it starts to
to really that can snowball whereas the
the the more that you make that a habit
of telling yourself the truth and
realizing uh hey I got to follow stay on
this path of discipline it's it becomes
easier it becomes easier and easier over
time so I think what seems daunting to
people initially it's not that daunting
when that becomes habit and and it's
just part of what you do I remember when
uh when we first started working
together tasing bruer uh Seth Stone the
delpon commander and I were uh were good
friends and we' go surf all the time and
we'd go surf after a we'd go out and
party you know hard on Friday night and
we'd like we're going to get up early
what we call Dawn Patrol was like
7:30 and then we started work we started
rolling out with Joo and Joo was like
cool I'll meet you guys at 4:45 and we
started going out in the dark and
initially that seemed insane like who
who can get up at 4:45 on a Saturday
morning that's is that even possible and
uh I remember uh me and Seth even even
when you weren't able to join us for
surf session we would go out all the
time at like 4:30 4:45 in the morning
we'd surf for an hour and a half and we'
paddle in as everyone else is paddling
out so no one else is out there and I
was like this is this is awesome so
might be the greatest thing I ever
taught
you is there any way there's there
anything better than paddling out when
it's dark it's like it's amazing it's
amazing it's awesome and is there
anything better than after you've been
surfing and catching every wave and
other people are padding out as you're
paddling back in that's pretty
satisfying as well too yeah because you
know like your your day started off like
no one can take that that time away from
you uh and I think that's a that's a
super powerful thing but it's it gets
easier over time and I think what makes
it easier for me is when I'm thinking if
I got to think long term like if if I'm
it's real easy to lie on myself when the
alarm goes off in the morning if I'm not
really I haven't really looked at the
schedule in detail and I don't know how
busy the day is going to be it's it's
easier to tell yourself oh you know I'll
find some time I I can sleep in it's
such a lie that's such a lie I'll find
some time it's such a lie don't do it
don't do it what what helps me not do it
is is the discipline preparation of like
looking at my schedule like no there
isn't any time like this is the time so
I can't get sucked into the algorithm of
you know scrolling through Instagram or
whatever it is I've got to use the next
hour that I have to get a good workout
in to set the whole tone for the whole
day um because there's not not going to
be another another time for me to be
able to do that so I I think that kind
of long-term thought of where I want to
be um you know on a day-to-day basis if
if I'm not if you're not really paying
attention and you're just kind of just a
slave to the what's next on the schedule
and you're not looking ahead it's real
easy I think to lie to yourself or or
easier certainly yeah and the more you
lie to yourself the easier it gets you
know when people come to work at Echelon
front and the first time they say like
well that wasn't really my and you can
hear like on a conference call like and
they kind of self-correct and then after
a while no one says you know if you've
been at echon front for three months you
don't say well that wasn't my fault or I
think actually you know Leif should have
done no you don't do that you don't say
that you recognize that that doesn't
work it's not allowed so when you when
you start lying to yourself it doesn't
get harder it gets easier and it becomes
harder to recognize like it stands out
like a sore thumb front when somebody
says oh that wasn't my fault or that's
because of the client when someone says
that it stands out like a sore thumb
it's just it everyone hears it well when
you lie to yourself and that's the Habit
that you're in it doesn't stand out at
all and that's why I'm a big proponent
if you just writing things down write
you you know what you got an excuse for
not working out just write it down see
what that thing looks like actually uh
we had a conversation on this podcast
the other day and I said I'm going to
I'm going to ask chat
GPT to write give me 5,000 excuses to
not work out
today and I so I did it like later on in
the day I was like I want 5,000 excuses
to not work out and it wouldn't give it
to me what it said it was like it gave
me a mental health answer like even
though and then I tried to uh give it a
better prompt I was like if a person
wanted to know why you they shouldn't
work out and give a legitimate reason
iied and it would not give
me any excuses to not work out is the AI
on our side the AI might be but is it an
ally it was very strange but it was very
weird that is weird yeah it wouldn't
give me the answer now I haven't tried
barred yet and I'll try the other ones
later and we'll see what we get there's
a there's a trooper in there like in the
coding thing he's like no excuses your
excuses are lies so there is no hack
there there is no there there's a man on
the inside we've got a man on the inside
yeah the AI is disciplined yes that's
what we're doing the AI is telling the
truth and that's what you need to do too
so if you're lacking
discipline you got to start telling
yourself the truth and if you do that
the discipline will find you that's what
we're doing you want to do more of this
go to the de
reset.com sign up we're getting after it
come get after it with us also joof
fuel.com Joost store.com origin usa.com
and Echelon front.com
we're there come get
it